it's a pick from drew's little yellow
book and that's our list
that i personally carry
that is very meaningful and important to
me because i love sharing today's pick
is a chocolate company that i cannot
live without it oh my god
look
look we're on it you see this it says
news on it
oh look this one too
[Applause]
i just can't believe that tony's
chocolate who i was this is choco lonely
and um they've embellished it in drew's
news wrapping and i just it means so
much to me so thank you tony's you're
one of my favorite chocolate companies
on the planet i was just promoting you
because i love you i had no idea that i
would be involved in this but more
importantly everybody is getting a
dollar gift card for tony's chocolate
the best and then
what's so cool
if you go to their website you get to
make your own custom wrappers that is so
cute
thank you tony
well because it's pasta week it's the
perfect pick
okay this is so amazing i freaking out i
did not know about this
and now i want to share it with you okay
it's a mashup of two of my very favorite
things on planet earth flowers and pasta
wow
this is gorgeous now it's by fiona
afshar and it's called floral pasta and
these handmade and designed pastas are
made by fiona in her kitchen in
california and now you can order this
handmade sourdough pasta right to your
door how cool is that this is beautiful
today it is blake lively's brand new
line of non-alcoholic mixers betty buzz
i love that picture of her can we show
that again i mean this is a campaign
picture i'm like yeah i want in on that
moment she's so beautiful inside and out
and her husband ryan ironically has a
gin
out there in the world but apparently
blake is not a drinker and she sent this
to me and it's a note from her i got a
note from blake lively i was like oh my
god
um and it says please uh drink
responsibly you may actually want to
keep this for yourself chill or enjoy
with ice and mint now these are meant to
either mix with alcohol because most
people want to imbibe sometimes not
others and so she made something that
works for everybody speaking of betty
buzz this is getting all the buzz
everywhere people are really talking
about this it's delicious mmm oh my god
i admire lemon what do you have oh my
god sparkling grapefruit yum ugh i know
what i'm drinking at my next soiree
thanks blake
blake
you're so awesome thank you so much for
sending this to me
zero calories oh
zero zero calories
oh my god it's so delicious you guys run
out betty buzz grab it cheers rusty
[Music]